there are roughly 40,000 different
spider species and if they're as big as
us they're all dangerous even the beira
kip lingi which is famous for being the
first mostly vegetarian spider known to
science if you think you'd only have to
worry about venomous or carnivorous
spiders you're dead wrong if they're not
venomous they can still be hungry and
even when they're not hungry you'll want
to look out for their giant legs which
could trample you you spiderwebs can be
hard to spot sometimes and most of us
have walked into one on more than a few
occasions but in a world where spiders
are the same size as us watching out for
webs would be a matter of life and
death when measured quantitatively by
weight and diameter a spider silk can be
five times stronger than steel and two
to 10 times as strong as Kevlar the
stuff that bulletproof vests are made
from